hey leute was geht auf und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
wir hoffen natürlich euch jetzt gut ich
habe heute max dabei was geht ab heute
mich erstmal sehr dass das so spontan
geklappt das recht auf jeden fall wenn
es ums essen geht bin ich immer dabei
leute die mich kennen müssen ja auch das
so in köln wohnt ja und ich habe es im
vorletzten video bei mir schon mal
angekündigt dass ich jetzt auch mal
wieder ein bisschen mehr mit essens
kontern oder bisschen mehr essen videos
machen möchte ich habe dir ja auch schon
erklärt worum ist ungefähr geht also an
sich jetzt nichts revolutionäres aber
einfach das waren halt wieder ein
bisschen mehr essen zeigen kann und da
habe ich mir gedacht ich reise von stadt
zu stadt und bestellen jetzt heute mit
dir ist ja hier profi auf dem gebiet
einfach das geilste was es so gibt es
also wirklich richtig heute ist wir sind
ja in köln gibt es ja so viel auf jeden
fall ist ja selber ich habe ja drei
jahre gewohnt und du kannst ja auch
gerne dabei helfen wenn wir es
vielleicht das krasseste essen aus via
und daher ich habe ich habe schon was im
kopf ich habe wirklich für die zuschauer
wirklich sehr viel schon durch bestellt
auch in videos und immer neues
durchprobiert und ich habe wirklich was
im kopf ich glaube das wird hier sehr
gut gefallen ich habe im letzten video
gesagt an sich geht es aber darum fünf
sternen natürlich und das restaurant mit
den meisten bewertungen lasst ihr im
kopf fit ist aber auch krank werden das
ist super gut bewertet das einzige ist
in köln wahrscheinlich vielen anderen
städten es ist das am besten oder am
häufigsten mit fünf sternen bewertet
pizzeria oder burger laden oder so aber
man will ja auch ein bisschen vielfalt
zeigen wo bürger sind wir gar nicht so
falsch bei dem an was ich denke das hat
sich für mich noch sehr gut an max hat
mir das gerade gezeigt just try absolut
ganz lustig habe ich schon gesagt habe
wir gewonnen und ich bin jeden morgen an
seinem fuß weg zur uni lange dies ja
deswegen habe mich immer gefragt was ist
das sagt ist das lecker ist was macht
der typ da weil er stand natürlich auch
oft dann draußen und wie oft war es auch
voll also dass schon eine schlange auch
deswegen irgendwie dachte ich mir du
musst es noch mal probiert aber ich
hasse bis heute das probiert ja deswegen
trifft sich das doch umso besser wir
schauen einfach mal nach was ist hier so
genau schauen rein und ich kann dir dann
die sachen vielleicht auch ein bisschen
erklären ja okay wenn ich jetzt hier
sehr ab und schießt bürger wissen was da
der unterschied zu einem normalen
cosplay das ist sollte
der ist eigentlich sehr sehr normal sehr
moderat der chili cheese bürger der
ansicht der ist auf jeden fall schön
spicy mache ich persönlich super gern
ich weiß nicht ob du gerne scharf ist
es geht so also wenn es nicht zu
schaffen ist schon aber wenn es so
einfach zu schaffen ist dann kann ich
das ja vielleicht wenn wenn du nicht
gerne scharf ist ist das schon eine
prise zu viel für dich über diese
special sachen siehst du da auch schon
die emprise aus sams wurzel also quasi
aus einer wurzelgemüse sind dass pommes
und die eine ganz eigene texturen jahres
eigenen geschmack haben so und es gibt
auch kochbananen kreis also bananen
pommes quasi ich würde sagen wenn wir
schon mal hier sind bestellen wir
einfach alles was ich einigermaßen
lecker und irgendwie können wir das
schon auf ist mein absoluter favorit von
der karte geoff reiss mit schicken
das ist so ein afrikanisches street food
also so gebratener nicht durchgebracht
man mit so einer ganz kräftigen guss und
botter reist mit einer zutat nachbarn
wirklich lecker ich würde für mich mal
anfangen also den cheeseburger den würde
ich sehr gerne probieren ob ich nun
meinen bergauf geballert gerne auf diese
freis die gibt es nur in kombination mit
gegrillten hähnchen streifen ja die
janka oder bewahrt man hier ja genau
gibt es auch ohne ich glaube dann nehme
ich die einfach mal ohne und mit
sozusagen focus kommt also sarkozy kommt
hier beides sehr sehr geil also ja ich
nehme auch recht freis ich nehme die
andere soßen okay dann habe ich für mich
glaube ich schon mal ausgewählt du ist
ja hier diese software soll aufpreis für
meine aussprache über ein kernproblem
dann würde ich auch mal vielleicht
probieren ja unbedingt sexy fw dichte
dass man noch aus mit hähnchen streifen
organisiert ich noch irgendwas ja ich
nehme mir auch eine beilage und zwar
nämlich mit einer die afro kochbananen
freising cocos kopf völlig ok das ist
der warenkorb us-bürger europe rise up
reis kocht man wirklich umsonst haben
ihr noch irgendwas was man noch dazu
gestellt oder weil jetzt gut abgedeckt
alles also ich glaube die wichtigsten
sachen für mich haben wir damit
na dann alex okay also du hast ja schon
zusammen gezählt was für harte und so
weiter dann bestelle ich das jetzt mal
und wir sehen uns vielleicht wieder und
ich hoffe mal das haut mich um
ich hoffe ich hoffe ich bin wirklich
heute an das video mit wohnen ansprüchen
gegangen sind wir schauen mal ja doch es
wird dir glaube sehr gut schmecken viele
leute da falsch ist aber verträgt bis
gleich
so leute werden uns jetzt kurz einmal
genau gegenüber platziert mit fliege er
liefert sogar das essen ist verdanken
ich bin sehr gespannt wo ich und auch
stadtrat ja ich stelle einfach mal auf
dem tisch das sind die am preis für mich
diesen betrieb das ist mein job das sind
die kochbananen frei ist und dass dann
doch und das hier sind auch die war ja
genau 23 das ist direkt mal auspacken
das ist die kochbanane koch sieht aber
bis ihr könnt auch so ein bisschen
schicken hält schenken wir sind ja hier
drin ist schicken und venedig auf die
preis und unter sieht dieses rotes du
sehr sehr lecker wichtig sei erstmal mit
dem traum ist anwalt burger
das ist da muss nicht warum das sind die
yamswurzel die richten so ein bisschen
wie ja das ist ja ein bisschen er sowie
herzhafte tours im ja sehen auch so ein
bisschen so aus jetzt weiß man gar nicht
was wasser ist hier von den von den
tipps von einer kokos pressebox hast du
kokos oder curry kokos aber wir können
ja beide in beiden probieren sowieso
alles mal vor das hier ist und sieht
auch krass aus das ist reines
rindfleisch
ja ja ja ich weiß ja nicht wie
entspannend ach so nicht so gerne mag
ich mal also ich achte schon darauf dass
ich das hört sich dann aber dass sich
lorenz vielleicht hast du denn
vielleicht kommen wir probieren
gemeinsam alles okay das ist wirklich
banane
diese größere uns ein bisschen was es da
so drumherum das entsteht ein anderen
automaten geht
diese normalerweise christi durch die
lieferung bis 16 uhr aber ich find's
einfach so verrückt so was ganz neues
schmeckt eigentlich eher wenig nach
banane oder also dieser bananen
durch dieses bananen aroma wird ein
bisschen verloren aber ich finde es
überhaupt nicht schlecht viel zeit total
geil
zwar ist jemand der in essen bestellt
und so etwas komplett neues suchen
so was habe ich noch nie gegessen in
diese richtung deshalb wollte ich sie
auch zeigen welche vip gäste besser mit
den linken besser kuba so sehr lecker
also das ist echt richtig gehabt hätte
ich nicht gedacht das hört sich für mich
nicht so an als würde ich das feiern
weil er also für die erste war schon
banal aber es ist jetzt nicht so dass
ich mit einer banane dann machen wir
hier mit weiter
das ist genau meine finger com schlimm
da was machen wir mit gabel essen was
denn da los du weißt ja wirklich merken
immer wieder ein bisschen mehr texturen
und müssen wir kratzen schausteller corp
das finde ich aber sogar ein schwenk
fast ein bisschen können wir diese mit
ihren weiß was ich meine ist ganz anders
sah man kaut mehr ist das so ein
bisschen weniger und so habt ihr lust
einmal dahin den chili poker immer zu
zeigen kurze erklärung dave zum beispiel
für den kennt der hat auch mit bestellt
und ich wollte das einmal weil ich habe
ja den normalen vorgang also haben ja
schon mehrmals nachbestellt absoluter
traum laden mit absoluten mega charme
und das spürt man im essen auch
irgendwie ist wirklich unglaublich an
sich relativ gleich aus nur noch nicht
nur ein bisschen wenig so mach ich es
muss auch einmal aus den beiden weil ich
ja auch gerade kochbanane mehr
aber das wird einfach mal interessant
weil du brauchst das hat so einen
leichten karamell geschmack ist leicht
melik und es einfach was anderes mal was
neues und ich meine das für mich einer
der vorteile vom leben in der großstadt
das man sowas überhaupt etwas stimmt das
muss ich auch sagen das vermisse ich
sehr ich habe zum beispiel hier habe ich
so dieses h variante gebaut für mich
entdeckt und war sehr sehr oft habe ich
mir solche sachen bestellt und mutter
gail und jetzt kannst du das nicht mehr
klar du kannst du irgendwie im rewe oder
so so fertige kaufen die sind auch okay
aber längst nicht so wie man das von
außen war das ist wirklich früchte guten
dann würde ich sagen förderpreis oder
oder wollte den bürger direkt mal
doch durch also toll aufpreis mit zu
großen stücken hähnchen nehmen wir so
komplett alles mit dem hähnchen nicht
nur so mal den reis probieren wenn das
ist einfach heftig ich war nicht wieder
das machen oder das ist so
geschmacksintensiv kommt das stimmt so
krass
er ist gespannt ob ich könnte auch
unserem ganzen pott nur 1 1
der ist wirklich heftig gut war sehr
geil ich muss jetzt einfach mal in den
saal reinweißen warum wird er sieht so
ich bin mal gespannt jetzt du bist ja
auch großer berger feld
ich habe auch schon sehr viele bürger
auf der welt probiert deswegen bin ich
jetzt mal gespannt ob der die chance hat
wobei klar ist was anderes wenn du
direkt im laden ist habe ob er die
chance hat vielleicht im darm eine top
10 20 klarzukommen und meinte ich die
wir den namen nicht für seine bürger
sollen für den job
diese ausgefallen und auch die bürger
sind grundsolide also die sind echt aus
der neiße ja ich habe viele leute
bestellen auch bot die bahn ist nur die
frage meinte der abrissbagger ob man das
irgendwie schmeckt aus der andersen bis
zu sagen es ein bisschen anders oder nee
nee nee ist relativ normal was ist sehr
geil finde ist das vielleicht ist ja
schon sollte für mich ist es immer
wichtig dass man merkt das gleiche gute
qualitäten und ist auch nicht nur durch
gebraten oder irgendwie war einen monat
im tiefkühllager das schmeckt man das
ist also das magistrat und auch die
saucen da drin und der salat schmeckt
auch sehr frisch von daher richtig guter
bürger schade eigentlich dass ich das
jetzt erst entdeckt haben und in der
zeit wo hier noch mehr
das nämlich öfter mal bestellt das
brötchen oder das brot ist auch das band
ist ein bisschen anders
und ein bisschen geld wert ist etwas
spezielles
ich finde das recht auf weiteren bau
heute ist ein tag dafür hat das essen
aber bei dir ist es bei dir ist ja
eigentlich jeder tag für das essen oder
das tier ist morgen sie auch heute weder
geiles essen wenn es wirklich war
es ist einfach ast und freue mich dass
ich noch gesagt wenn leute so funktional
essen nur essen um auf nährwerte als an
dem schnellst möglich effizient sagt zu
werben was macht ihr mit eurem leben ist
ein highlight jedes essen oder leute die
halt voll in ihrem fitness film sind und
nur so weiß nicht also na das hat
bestimmt auch wenn man sich komplett
gesund und immer nur auf diesem
kalorienbedarf und gesunde vitamine 8
keine ahnung hat man ein besseres
lebensgefühl aber dann hab ich doch
einfach mal ein richtig geilen sage oder
so es stimmt ich würde sagen ich habe
die ganze zeit beim und feuerwehr schon
elfmal auch und dann sehen wir
vielleicht noch mal wieder also leute
werden auf jeden fall beide sehr großen
hunger und wenn man dann so direkt
fertiges essen kriegt das knallt auf
jeden fall ein ja auf jeden fall muss
ich sagen sehr sehr guter tipp das war
extrem lecker wir sind noch nicht ganz
fertig aber der bürger war ultra auf
diese teile habe ich nur wenn ich euch
auf jeden fall empfehlen wenn ihr mal in
köln seit ich habe mir gedacht wir
wollen jetzt nicht irgendwie punkte
verteilen auch wenn es für mich neun
oder zehn punkte wären 14
sondern ich werde das ja in
verschiedenen städten machen jetzt ist
köln auf jeden fall das absolute
highlight wir hatten jetzt auch nur
meine heimat schafft das war ein
bisschen lob als nächstes kommt
wahrscheinlich düsseldorf ihr könnt auch
super gerne weitere städte in die
kommentare schreiben wo ich das sehr
gerne mal machen soll
danke dass sie mitmachen das ist ja
gerne schaut auf jeden fall mal bei ihm
vorbei da gibt es ja noch viel viel mehr
essens kontern verlegen ich euch in der
video beschreibung und wir sehen uns in
drei tagen wieder gibt's neues video
haut rheinkanal abonnieren das war's